[Música]
ruanda está preparada para acoger a los
solicitantes de asilo que reino unido va
a enviar a ese país en el marco del
nuevo y polémico plan anunciado por el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
y que aún debe ser aprobado por el
parlamento de ese país la medida según
el gobierno busca combatir la
inmigración ilegal y las bandas
delictivas que explotan a las personas
que buscan refugio cruzando el canal de
la mancha situado entre francia e
inglaterra el plan que ha sido criticado
por los partidos de oposición y las
organizaciones no gubernamentales que
ayudan a los refugiados es parte del
objetivo del político conservador de
reformar el sistema de inmigración para
recuperar el control de las fronteras
esto tras el prat la salida de reino
unido de la unión europea y es que según
la prensa local británica el año pasado
28 mil 526 solicitantes de asilo
cruzaron el canal en pequeños botes un
alce de 8.404 respecto al año 2020 pero
se estima que la cifra de este año
supere ya los 30 mil las 30.000 personas
que cruzan el canal
destino a reino unido para ello entonces
para hablar sobre este tema esta idea
del gobierno británico quiero saludar a
natalia pérez que para ella es concejala
de la municipalidad de heart hammersmith
y fulham en londres gracias natalia por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 muy buena mañana de viernes
muy buenos días dragón y ya toda la
audiencia de directo américa muchas
gracias por tenerme esta mañana con
ustedes gracias a ti natalia por estar
con nosotros usted como política
migrante como esta medida y cuáles son
sus implicaciones
si yo soy inmigrante colombiana llegué
en el año 2000 esta política del
gobierno conservador se me hace es
sumamente inhumana y sumamente cruel en
el reportaje que estaba haciendo
anteriormente hacía alusión a cómo las
organizaciones de caridad se habían
pronunciado en contra esta decisión y no
sólo han sido las organizaciones de
caridad sino también el movimiento
iglesias también la convención de
naciones unidas que protege los derechos
de los refugiados también la comisión
europea que protege los derechos humanos
califican la medida de ser nombrado
completamente cruel y de correr el
riesgo también de incumplir con el
convenio que hay a nivel internacional
con el convenio ahora natale hablemos de
la legalidad de este plan en ese marco
esta política estaría violando como
usted lo dijo convenios internacionales
y también de derechos humanos
si un convenio está el convenido con
naciones unidas que buenas unidades que
sí que las personas tienen derecho a
aplicar asilo nadie es ilegal hasta que
sus procesos de aplicación así no sean
decididos
fueron el riesgo de incumplir esas
reglas hay que tener en cuenta que
en los 90s en este país es el omonia muy
muy grande también y migratorio y las
estadísticas en ese momento de migración
en nada se comparan con las que tienen
en este momento que están mucho más
disminuidas
anteriormente se han dado programas
mucho más humanitarios mucho más mucho
más conmiseración y que han tratado a
migrantes que buscan acciones del país
de una manera más hospitalaria y
humanitaria lo que piensan hacer es muy
cruel porque pienso en básicamente
retornar a todas las personas que
intentan llegar a algo de remover las
básicamente a ruanda un país
y que lo han criticado porque no tiene
una democracia porque viola los derechos
humanos estamos hablando de un proceso
que puede poner en riesgo a personas que
busquen asilo que vienen de la misma
ruanda porque allá por ejemplo hay unas
estadísticas muy terribles con respecto
a la violación de derechos humanos de
personas con otras preferencias sexuales
entonces es una es una gran
contradicción y viola claramente
derechos humanos claro no tal es usted
lo acaba de decir porque ruanda además
ubicada a 6 mil 500 kilómetros de reino
unido el propio verón británico también
como usted lo señalaba ha criticado a
las autoridades ruandesas en no respetar
digamos los derechos humanos de las
personas y sobre todo de las minorías
porque con el gobierno ruandés se hizo
esta medida
personalmente
aybar estas son las que apuntan lo mismo
si cree que claramente es una cortina de
humo en este momento hay una crisis
coyuntural muy grande para el gobierno
conservador boris johnson con sus con su
canciller fueron multados la semana
pasada por haber incumplido las normas
que ellos mismos decretaron en la época
de la pandemia que no permitían que
grupos
socializarán para evitar el contagio del
colon habidos y que pasó el primer
ministro con con sus colegas se
reunieron incumplió en las reglas y la
policía metropolitana de londres la
semana pasada los multón
entonces creemos que es una manera
estratégica para ellos de generar y de
atención en otra área y no lidiar con el
llamado que hay colectivo para que él
renuncie de su posición como primer
ministro claro natalia y volviendo
digamos a este tema migratorio hay mails
hay manera de garantizar y hacer que se
respeten estos derechos de los migrantes
que
van a ser devueltos a ruanda cuando sean
digamos capturados tratando de llegar al
reino unido por el canal de la mancha
claro que sí en este momento y programas
que
proveen rutas seguras e ilegales en este
momento tenemos el gobierno tiene varios
programas por ejemplo con con personas
que tienen de afganistán con personas
que vienen de siria y como personas que
vienen de ucrania
son modelos que han utilizado que
permiten el acceso legal y seguro de
migrantes que buscan proteger sus
derechos y garantizar su derecho a la
vida en otras en otras tierras si el
modelo existe para otras personas porque
no puede existir
para marie migrantes también que quieren
llegar y buscar asilo claro usted tocaba
ese tema y también quería preguntarle
preguntarle al respecto estamos viendo
pues un éxodo masivo de las personas que
huyen de la guerra en ucrania que ha
tenido las puertas digamos en la unión
europea y también el reino unido le ha
facilitado el proceso de migración
teniendo en cuenta que ya reino unido no
pertenece a la unión europea ayer
precisamente
el director de la organización mundial
de la salud aseguró que los problemas
están siendo digamos racializados los
problemas de las personas los migrantes
y las personas que huyen de los
conflictos digamos de los blancos y los
negros cree que esto es una medida
también realizada que está tomando el
gobierno británico
el gobierno británico con concreto y
patel también dice que ha liderado este
proceso claramente lleva de tiempo atrás
intentando promover políticas que son
muy hostiles hacia la comunidad de
migrantes hacia la comunidad
que busca asilo en este país y esta es
una medida más y simplemente refuerza
una narrativa muy negativa frente a los
derechos que tienen miles de personas al
buscar una mejor calidad de vida y
proteger sus derechos
podría ser una de las razones claramente
natalia esta malla todavía sin embargo
tiene que ser aprobado por el parlamento
del reino unido- qué posibilidades tiene
de ser aprobada podemos dar por sentado
que esta medida ya va a ser un hecho va
a ser ley
estaba escuchando
comentaristas esta mañana en la bbc y
hay muchas iniciativas en deferencia a
los derechos humanos de los derechos de
las y los migrantes y personas en el
sector pues legal que piensan desafiar
este modelo y esta política en las
cortes así que hay ciertos obstáculos
legales que tienen que ser aprobados
antes de que esta medida pueda pueda
implementarse yo personalmente creo que
mucha gente está en desacuerdo todos los
partidos de oposición las iglesias y las
organizaciones de caridad
los movimientos comunitarios y también
inmigrantes que han llegado ya con su
estatus de resurge aquí están en contra
y yo personalmente creo que van a
encontrar varios obstáculos es que es
una medida que puede arriesgo muchísimas
personas por ejemplo hay intérpretes de
afganistán que ayudaron al gobierno a
interpretar en afganistán que están
buscando por ejemplo asilo en este país
de la pregunta es nos van a los van a
remover a ruanda cuando han ayudado y
han sido solidarios también con causas
que el gobierno ha liderado y en ese
orden días digamos que no solamente la
gente que cruza por el grande la mancha
sino la gente que está digamos a la
espera de ese asilo puede ser devuelta a
ruanda
es lo que dice en ese momento que
cualquier persona que bueno que hombre
más que todo que intenten llegar los van
a remover y robando
aquí también piensa en la parte
operativa como lo piensen hacer estamos
también en medio de una crisis climática
y climática una emergencia climática es
implicaría el retorno masivo irregular
por por vías aéreas quien pactó a tener
esto a nivel ambiental también
desde cualquier ámbito existente que se
le mire en realidad no es no es
operativo y claramente apunta que es una
cortina de humo para distraer sobre
crisis
coyuntural de liderazgo claro natalia
muchas muchas cosas están sobre lo más
en este punto pero esta medida digamos
que frenaría la migración irregular como
lo busca el gobierno británico
yo personalmente no creo que lo vaya a
frenar pongámonos en los zapatos
de personas que tienen que salir de sus
países por violación a los derechos
humanos yo soy madre yo soy madre a un
niño de 10 años y yo tomara la decisión
de irme de un país y poner a mi hija en
riesgo en un barco en un bote y lo haría
porque las razones que me llevan a celos
son muy trágicas y son muy dramáticas y
claramente veo un riesgo para la vida de
mi familia y
de mi hija entonces hay que pensar un
poco en las razones criteria de este
movimiento y tener como más compasión en
esos preciosos esto no va a detener
estos procesos de migración pues este
modelo ya ha sido
implementado en australia
y hace unos años que han analizado el
modelo el impacto que tuvo muchas
personas fueron a pasar a la removieron
a las islas y la salud mental de las
personas que removieron la crisis que
esto generó fue terrible y además no
frenó las rutas migratorias que existían
natale ya para finalizar usted llegó a
reino unido en el año 2000 ya hace 22
años que ha cambiado en materia
migratoria desde que usted llegó hasta
la actualidad ha sido peor para los
inmigrantes
en ese momento el gobierno conservador
claramente tiene unas políticas mucho
más
derecha mucho más racistas mucho más si
no soy gas hay muchísima atención social
cuando yo llegué estaba en contra el
partido laborista yo soy concejala al
partido laborista y tenía unas críticas
y mucho más humanas y mucho más
hospitalarias y como dijo en los 90 son
años para ser pasados si vemos las
estadísticas comparativamente hablando
eran mucho más altas
y eso y eso se ve en las políticas que
tiene el gobierno actual son son más
radicales y su más claramente en humanos